In this segment, we discuss
a little more the
mean squared error.
Consider some estimator.
It can be any estimator, not
just the sample mean.
We can decompose the mean
squared error as
a sum of two terms.
Where does this formula
come from?
Well, we know that for any
random variable Z, this
formula is valid.
And if we let Z be equal to
the difference between the
estimator and the value that
we're trying to estimate, then
we obtain this formula here.
The expected value of our random
variable Z squared is
equal to the variance of that
random variable plus the
square of its mean.
Let us now rewrite these
two terms in a
more suggestive way.
We first notice that theta
is a constant.
When you add or subtract the
constant from a random
variable, the variance
does not change.
So this term is the same as
the variance of theta hat.
This quantity here,
we will call it
the bias of the estimator.
It tells us whether theta hat
is systematically above or
below than the unknown parameter
theta that we're
trying to estimate.
And using this terminology, this
term here is just equal
to the square of the bias.
So the mean squared error
consists of two components,
and these capture different
aspects of an estimator's
performance.
Let us see what they are
in a concrete setting.
Suppose that we're estimating
the unknown mean of some
distribution, and that our
estimator is the sample mean.
In this case, the mean squared
error is the variance, which
we know to be sigma squared over
n, plus the bias term.
But we know that the sample
mean is unbiased.
The expected value of the sample
mean is equal to the
unknown mean.
And so the bias contribution
is equal to zero.
Now, for the sake of a
comparison, let us consider a
somewhat silly estimator which
ignores the data all together,
and always gives you an
estimate of zero.
In this case, the mean squared
error is as follows.
Since our estimator is just a
constant, its variance is
going to be equal to zero.
On the other hand, since theta
hat is zero, this term here is
just the constant,
theta, squared.
And this gives us the
corresponding
mean squared error.
Let us now compare the
two estimators.
We will plot the mean squared
error as a function of the
unknown parameter, theta.
For the sample mean estimator,
the mean squared error is
constant, it does not depend on
theta, and is equal to this
value, sigma squared over n.
On the other hand, for the
zero estimator, the mean
squared error is equal
to theta squared.
How do they compare?
Which one is better?
At this point, there's no
way to say that one is
better than the other.
For some theta, the sample
mean has a smaller mean
squared error.
But for other theta, the zero
estimator has a smaller mean
squared error.
But we do not know where the
true value of theta is.
It could be anything.
So we cannot say that one is
better than the other.
Of course, we know that
the sample mean is
a consistent estimator.
As n goes to infinity,
it will give you the
true value of theta.
And this is a very desirable
properties that the zero
estimator does not have.
But if n is moderate, the
situation is less clear.
If we have some good reason to
expect that the true value of
theta is somewhere in the
vicinity of zero, then the
zero estimator might be a better
one, because it then
will achieve a smaller
mean squared error.
But in a classical statistical
framework, there is no way to
express a belief of this kind.
In contrast, if we were
following a Bayesian approach,
you could provide a prior
distribution for theta that
would be highly concentrated
around zero.
This would express your beliefs
about theta, and would
provide you with the guidance
to choose between the two
estimators, or maybe suggest
an even better estimator.
In any case, going back to this
formula, this quantity,
the variance of the estimator
plays an important role in the
analysis of different
estimators.
And the more intuitive variant
of this quantity is its square
root, which is the standard
deviation of the estimator,
and is usually called
the standard
error of the estimator.
We can interpret the standard
error as follows.
We have the true
value of theta.
Then on day one, we collect
some data, we perform the
estimation procedure, and we
come up with an estimate.
On day two, we do the same
thing, but independently.
We collect a new set of
data, and we come up
with another estimate.
And so on.
We do this many times.
We use different data
sets to come up
with different estimates.
And because of the randomness
in the data, these estimates
may be all over the place.
Well, the standard error tells
us how spread out all these
estimates will be.
It is the standard
deviation of this
collection of estimates.
Having a large standard error
means that our estimation
procedure is quite noisy, and
that our estimates have some
inherent randomness.
And therefore, also have
a lack of accuracy.
That is, they cannot be
trusted too much.
That's the case of a large
standard error.
Conversely, a small standard
error would tell us that the
estimates would tend
to be concentrated
close to each other.
As such, the standard error
is a very useful piece of
information to have.
Besides designing and
implementing an estimator, one
usually also tries to find a
way to calculate and report
the associated standard error.